i
carries through
your heart
feel the music hear the words and
express yourself the winner wins their
server money they're so much more
excited on the price is right aren't
they yeah
[Music]
i was actually scared you were about to
come what's the name of your best dance
move let's go moonwalk
moonwalk
you said let's go moonlock like we were
playing family feud or something
let's go moonwalk survey set your best
move is the moonwalk
not in those shoes it isn't
that's a sticky shoe didn't want to wear
the crocs huh
i'm assuming if you have those shoes you
also have crocs so
yeah i think they come as a two for one
i'm pretty sure
young lady what is your name
yeah no i can hear the white girl holler
from the wilderness yeah
that's how you find each other at a club
right
like coyotes in the wilderness
what would you say in one word describes
your dance style
inconsistent
is the best way to say no rhythm that
i've ever heard in my entire life yeah
i'm just kind of inconsistent that's all
you know
give me the one name for your best dance
move
i'm gonna call it the frozen shoulder
the goddamn frozen shoulder
i don't know why i'm up here oh yeah we
do thank you so much
what's the one word you would use to
describe your dance style
crazy
yeah i believe that 100
[Laughter]
what is the name of your best dance move
freaking on you freaking oh i forgot to
mention rule number one no touching me
oh freaking on you like tlc oh okay so
your bed the name of your best dance
move is freaking on you
i think so
tlc
[Applause]
okay let me grab this thank you so much
you head on back there
katie i forgot to mention you don't get
to pick the song you dance to you know
that right oh okay
if you could think of one word
that would describe your dance style
what would that one word be
whiteness
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're welcome to keep that as an answer
if you would like it i'll lock it in oh
you lock it
that's official as [ __ ] nobody's ever
said that before lock it in good answer
good answer good answer good answer
survey set uh okay
give me the name
of your best dance move
i lock back in whiteness
you're doubling down on whiteness i'll
double down on whiteness
i actually think this is a good move for
you
this dude spins on his head i will [ __ ]
myself
if he's like
i don't think it's gonna happen but
i think you're closer to [ __ ]
yourself than spinning on your head
young lady what's your name
rachel who are you here with tonight i'm
with jeff from jersey
jeffrey hey [ __ ] gym from jersey
[ __ ] bingo
[Applause]
hey what are you [ __ ] kidding me get
out of here
tell me something what is your name my
name is melena malena malena how would
you rank yourself as a dancer
i'm okay i like your style well it
depends on how big his dick is okay
you are
my fire
the one
the
desire
believe
listen man i like it like you kept the
tame you stayed straight in the
pedophile handbook
you are
my fire
the one
will
desire
believe
when i
say
i
wanted thy way
you are
my fire
the one
the desire
[Music]
believe
when i
say
i
wanted that way
[Music]
when i
say
[Music]
it can't reach through
[Music]
[Music]
i
wanted that
way
[Music]
all right well listen yeah i guess you
missed the part of the show where i told
you he had herpes you'll never forget
this night who's katie's server i don't
think she'd know listen to the words
feel the music here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
desire
to believe
when i
say
i
wanted thy way
he is clearly saving the good stuff for
round two
[Applause]
we're gonna see some of that whiteness
rachel
jeff from jersey
you forget about
it you ready
you are
my fire
the one
the desire
believe
when i
say
i
want it
that way
antonio get in there
hold on
[Applause]
[Music]
hold on hold on hold on don't give it
away don't give it away yet don't give
it away
[Applause]
hold on i'm thinking i'm thinking by the
way i'm i'm thinking that i should
change the first long line of the song
to
you have
a boner
[Laughter]
okay
yes
now
milena there's two rounds now okay you
ready
[Applause]
yeah i said yeah yeah you get that out
of there you don't want that wire in the
way his boner that's for sure
you ready girl
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you are
my fire
[Applause]
[Music]
i
want it that way
[Music]
[Applause]
hey antonio antonio antonio
i can understand if you can't get up for
a couple seconds are you gonna
breakdance
what's about to happen
[Music]
okay all right all right here we go
antonio how come you're not doing [ __ ]
right now what's going on with it
i'm so excited to see what's about to
happen i don't know if i'm more excited
to see why
you cleaned that spot
or to see what the [ __ ] comes out of you
i can't decide
they're both so amazing i i
oh ho ho ho ho ho ho ho
never mind
someone
[Music]
all right you ready guys here we go
you are
[Music]
when i
say
i
wanna
[Music]
[Music]
but when i say
i
want it that way
tell me why he ain't nothing but a
heartache
tell me why ain't nothing but a mistake
tell me why i only wanna hear you say
i
wanna
that way
yeah
antonio i'm not gonna lie i thought you
were gonna take off that shirt my man
yo you'd have brought down the [ __ ]
house
whiteness
wow all right
but let's not forget who put on the
[ __ ] show
[Applause]
[Music]
come right up in the light
let's hear it everybody
[Music]
hey hey you know what yeah we'll give
both you 50 bucks that was amazing
you're the best thank you so much my man
thank you so much let them hear one more
time everybody let them hear
[Applause]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]